[MUSIC]
[APPLAUSE]
>> So now
>> All right
>> Welcome back to Stanford.
>> It's great to be here and it's nice
to be back physically with people in
the room so it's terrific
>> Yeah and
as you can tell my classmates and I are so
excited that you're here with us today.
And this conversation is extra special for
me because your story hit so
close to home.
Like you, my dad is from South India,
he is an alumnus of IIT and
immigrated here about 30 years ago,
with grit and determination,
he's right here in the audience.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> He's a role model for me and so are
you, so truly thank you for being here.
>> The real pleasure is mine,
it's very nostalgic.
I was just telling John,
I saw a volleyball court outside Stanford
was the end of my fledgling volleyball
career coming here and seeing
>> [LAUGH]
>> How good people were, but
it's really nice to be back.
>> Lots of talent around here.
And when you first became the CEO
of Google, it created quite a buzz.
Your Wikipedia page had over 350 edits
just in the week that you became
the leader,
have you seen some of these edits?
>> [LAUGH]
>> Advice I would have for
all of you is don't read
about yourself online.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Well, we thought it'd be a good way
to start the conversation
>> [LAUGH]
>> By visiting some of these Wikipedia
edits, some of our favorite
ones with fact versus fake news
your Wikipedia page edition.
>> [LAUGH]
>> First of all someone claimed.
>> That you decided to join IIT at
a young age at 8 years old, fact or fake?
>> I think that was fake, my parents
were tired of me they sent me to school,
I think when I was about two and a half
to kindergarten I was pretty young when I
came to Stanford but that is not true.
>> [LAUGH]
>> At the same time everyone wanted to
claim you from their
hometown in high school.
So there are quite a few
edits to your page
on which high school you came from.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Where did you go?
>> There are two schools which are right,
but the final school is VanaVani
which is inside the campus where
your dad went to college, so
that's where I went to school.
>> Wow, okay, so the person that said you
were homeschooled was definitely wrong.
>> [LAUGH]
>> I don't think I was homeschooled,
unless it involved playing cricket.
>> [LAUGH]
>> I wasn't homeschooled.
>> Well, on that note, [LAUGH]
>> [LAUGH]
>> Were you the captain of
your high school cricket team?
>> I would have loved to be
>> [LAUGH]
>> But I was quite far from it, yeah.
>> In another life [LAUGH].
So now that we have
>> In the Metaverses, yeah.
>> [LAUGH] >.
You're speaking my language [LAUGH].
>> So now that we have the fiction out of
the way, we can turn to some of the facts.
You grew up in Indian with
limited access to technology and
when you discovered technologies
it had a profound impact on you.
How did you go from an initial delay in
technology to devoting your career to
access to technology for all?
>> Growing up for
me every technology transition
was very vivid even as a kid because
I had to wait a long time for it.
We were on a waitlist for
rotary telephone it took five years to
be on the waitlist and get the form.
I would go to get my grandparents
blood test results and
it would be an hour round trip each way.
And he would go all the way to
the hospital and they would say,
it's not ready today come back tomorrow.
And then this phone came and I could
call and they would tell me whether
the results were ready or not and so
to me, that was like, super profound.
And people who would come
to our house to make calls,
I saw how it created a sense of community.
So I've always had this vivid sense
of how technology can make a profound
difference and so a lot of what I've tried
to do is bring that access to technology.
What I got, I got a lot more
of it when I came to Stanford.
Walking to Sweet Hall at the time and
seeing rows of computers
was life changing for me.
And I was very inspired by Negroponte
is one laptop per child project.
And even today, a lot of what I'm able to
do at Google, be it make cheaper phones
through Android, bring the next billion
people online or Chromebooks and
try to make affordable laptops, all hit
close to that mission so, definitely.
>> Yeah, and I can tell,
the way that you speak about technology,
it had this impact on you and
it manifested in your studies as well.
You got your engineering degree from IIT,
and
then a master's here at
Stanford in Engineering.
And we're about to pursue a career
in academia and get your PhD.
Clearly that's not the path
you ended up taking.
What changed your mind, why did you
decide to leave academia at the time?
>> I still want to know I'll
have a conversation with my dad.
I think I disappointed him a little bit
>> [LAUGH]
>> Not getting that PhD, but
I literally came to Silicon Valley for
me it was asked literal, for
me this was the place where
semiconductors are built, I came here for
the silicon in Silicon Valley.
And, I did my PhD student in material
science, I was studying semiconductor
physics and definitely that's
what I thought I would do.
A few things one is I was surrounded by
other grad students who had worked on at
the time what was the rage,
it was a superconductors,
what was called high TC superconductors.
And I realized many of them had spent
their life and it didn't happen and so
that gave me pause.
And I think something you all probably
deal with being in the Valley, there's so
much happening outside.
There's a lot that beckons outside and
so I was definitely interested in that.
I had financial reasons to go get a job
and so the combination of all that made me
go out and be in industry and
in a great learning moment.
The semiconductor industry
is extraordinarily cyclical.
In my first year of the company at work,
we hired 3000 people and
the next year we laid off 1700 people.
And so you get out and
you go through that life learning.
But that was the early days
of the internet too, and
definitely seeing what the promise
the internet had and connecting
it back to what I wanted to do was what
led me find my way back to Google.
And I went to business school
along the way, not here, but
another great school and
eventually made it back to the Valley.
>> Yeah, it seems like you saw the rapid
change of technology outside of academia.
>> Yeah, Boat Stanford itself
is a special place I think there
are in most faculty here it's
a very symbiotic relationship which
I've always thought is unique
amongst many places in the world.
And so definitely both being in
the campus you get a good sense for
what's happening outside.
And going to industry here you
really get a sense for the dynamism.
We take it for granted but as I travel
around the world, most people outside
are trying to understand how
the Valley works and how to do better.
So it's an extraordinary place.
>> Yeah and many of us here are in
a transitory period of our lives.
Figuring out which industry
we want to go and impact.
You've been at Google for
now quite a while, 20 years.
And faced several crossroads
during your time.
Sometimes choosing to leave an industry
is as difficult as choosing to stay.
What drew you to stay at
Google over the past 20 years
>> It's been very busy partly that [LAUGH]
and you know I mean,
it's an extraordinary place.
I think the breadth of talent you see,
the kinds of projects you get exposed to,
you're on the cutting edge of everything.
It's like, I'm not a surfer,
but I use this analogy.
I don't know why, but it's like I've
tried a couple of times and it failed.
But it feels like, surfing and being
on the edge of something all the time.
So definitely I enjoy that.
And a big part of it is,
if you look at our products,
search works everywhere around the world.
We take pride in providing it and
it's accessible to everyone as long as
they have computing and connectivity
whether you're here at Stanford or
kid in rural Indonesia,
Google works for you.
And that's the philosophy we
bring across our products.
The chi meI will be perhaps with YouTube.
So we think about scale,
being able to reach people and
make technology more accessible and
it's what I wanted to do in my life.
And so it's a privilege to do it.
>> Yeah.
And there's no shortage
of products to work on.
>> There's no shortage,
sometimes too many at Google.
But that's kind of the story.
>> Yeah.
One of the early products that
you worked on was Chrome.
You led the team and
initially there was some pushback.
High development costs
competitors in the space.
But you had conviction that
the browser was the way to go.
Where did the conviction come from?
And how did you convince skeptics
that Chrome was the future?
>> Now that time Eric was our CEO,
Eric Schmidt.
And I remember him being angry once he
said it because he realized we were trying
to build a browser and he was like, do you
know what it takes to build a browser?
It takes because he had gone
through the browser battles.
He definitely didn't, [LAUGH].
You know, was hesitant for us to do it.
Partly how did I do it?
I didn't tell tell people [LAUGH].
For a while I just had a small team and
worked on it.
And only when we had something to show,
we had a chance to show the product and
that got people excited and
so but it's a good lesson.
I think if you have a set of committed
people, passionate people you can achieve
even I couldn't have foreseen
what it would eventually become.
But shows the power of a small
group of committed people and
actually not knowing the odds
of what you're working on.
So I think both helps.
>> Yeah, and you can obviously see
the direction that Chrome grew into as
one of the most popular browsers today.
And you really have seen Google
transition from pre IPO to
the trillion dollar company it is today.
It's challenging to scale
an organization of that size.
Over the years, what do you think
Google has done well as it scaled,
>> I mean, the it is a complex thing
scaling a company,
I would say thinks we have gotten right.
The first thing that struck me about
Google when I joined the company,
it was very different in the sense
that it was a very optimistic place.
So there are places in which
if you walked the hallways and
you spoke to people in the UN ideas.
People expanded on them.
Most of the times people try to tell you
why things won't work I felt the spirit
was different people will tell
you view That's a great idea.
You could do it this way and
it would be better.
So that struck me that optimism,
the fact that you can innovate,
make things better solve problems,
I think is the spirit of tried to create
now and it takes a lot of hard work.
You have to encourage innovation.
One of the counterintuitive things is,
companies become more
conservative as they grow.
They have a lot more cash,
they have a lot more resources.
But companies tend to become more
conservative in their decision making.
And so encouraging the company
to take risks and innovate and
be okay with failure and
reward effort, not outcomes.
And that's very hard to do in
an organization people tend to reward
outcomes.
And which means over time, the
organization becomes more conservative,
they take safer bets, and so on.
So a lot of scaling is about making sure
you preserve the good things you had in
the early days and that gets harder
as the company becomes bigger,
you're to work harder at it.
But I think a big part of what we try
hard to do is keep that culture of
innovating with technology,
building products,
shipping things, and so
that's one of the many things but yeah.
>> Yeah, and maintaining that
culture as the company grows.
Is not easy it's a difficult endeavor.
What were some of the other kind of
growing pains that you've seen Google have
over the last couple of years
>> Yeah I mean definitely a lot I mean
when you're a small company,
think about the size of the business
schools all of you have shared context.
You understand better what others
are going through and so you have better
context around everything that's going on
a larger company definitely gets harder.
Right.
And Google was built on everyone.
It's a very open culture.
Even today.
One of the most common things people tell
me when they come from other companies is.
They're shocked at how
transparent the company is,
you've literally access to what's
happening across the company.
But it can be overwhelming and
just because you have transparency
doesn't mean you have context.
It's very different from when
organizations are smaller.
So, that's been a big part of trying to
figure out how to scale up the company.
And how do you organize more independently
coordinate only when needed,
but can have more parts of
the company move smaller units.
And that's a hard balance to get right.
>> And
now you're at the helm of Google and
you see all of these teams
working in different directions.
But one thing that you've been vocal
about and enthusiastic about is AI.
You've said AI is the most important
thing humanity has ever worked on and
many of us will go on to work with AI or
advanced computing in some form.
How should we be thinking about AI to
help humanity versus harm humanity?
>> No, it's a great question.
When I became CEO, one of the biggest
directional changes we made, as we said,
we're going to approach
everything as AI first and
we're applying it across
everything we do in the company.
It's a big part of the r&d we spend.
And the progress is palpable every year,
it's exciting there's a lot of progress.
I think we concretely see
the evidence of just when
you look at the scale at
which translation works.
Or in search how we use AI or in Gmail
when you type and we give suggestions.
It's applied across all our products.
And so it definitely, we can see the path
by which we're making things better.
I think will profoundly transform
pretty much every sector.
You see the potential in areas
like healthcare I think it'll
still take a decade for
it to fully play out but we definitely see
the potential question of how do you
make sure we develop it in a way.
I think that the essential
struggle of humanity with every
technology Is harnessing it so
that it benefits society.
You can see the same
debates about the internet,
even before you think about AI,
has the internet been a force of good?
Obviously, has it had effects,
which we didn't fully anticipate?
Yes, and that's the debate and we
are working about how best to address it.
With AI I think we need to
think about it earlier.
So, part of how we are approaching,
we have clearly articulated publicly a set
of AI principles, and publicly stated
it and we publish a lot of research,
we open source technology, but
that's only part of the problem.
I think academic institutions
need to play a big role.
We were a founding member for
Stanford's AI Institute Hai and
proud to be a supporter there.
I think they're doing terrific work.
But in academic institutions,
nonprofits and
the public private partnership
government will end up having a roll.
There has to be thoughtful
regulation about AI.
You have to get the balance right so
that there is innovation, but
I think it's important to think it
through earlier than other technologies.
So I think and so
doing it an engaging all the stakeholders
is the only way I can
think of approaching it.
>> So it seems like it's a living
breathing framework that evolves as AI
also evolves.
>> That's right.
And it needs to involve many people from
many different institutions
to make it work.
>> Yeah.
I want to touch on your point on
technology being forward about technology
and thinking about the benefits and
harms as we're building it.
In a post COVID world,
many of us have realized the importance
of human connection, and
we crave human connection yet sometimes
technology can breed disconnection.
How are you thinking about the future
of quality connections with each other,
as technology becomes
a larger part of our lives?
>> I mean, look technology is an enabler.
Ultimately it's people in society, we have
to organise around how we use technology.
I think you're raising
a very important point and,
thinking through about how
technology is not isolating, or
immersive in a way in which it
prevents you from engaging,
I think genuinely is a good topic.
I think all of us who have kids,worry
about it and struggle about it.
I did like when our sons were
playing in the middle school band,
it's what you want to see them do more of.
But every generation always is very
worried about technology of the future.
It's always been true
when you look back at it.
And so I think that's part of the process.
Technology done correctly,
can enable interactions in the real world.
One of the companies we spun out of Google
which was Niantic I did that precisely
that with Pokeyman and
got people to move about and do stuff in
the real world which I found inspiring.
But I think over time,
part of even if we get augmented reality,
right, today when you see people on their
phones walking on the streets immersed.
You see that in some ways technology
forces you they engage with it.
It hasn't adapted enough
to how humans live life.
And so part of solving, more natural
ways by which you can interact with
computing be it voice be computing,
understanding what you're looking at,
may actually help us do this better,
than wrongly can be even more isolating,
but done correctly with
the right attributes.
I think it can help bridge that gap.
And so I think that's a potential for
AR if done correctly.
>> Yeah, so it's thinking in
advance about the implications and
then being there as
the technology develops.
>> That's right?
>> Yeah.
I want to take a step back and
look at Google more as a whole.
Some of the biases we've talked
about with AI but more more broadly,
what goes on with Google's culture.
In 2018 employees staged a walkout for
women's rights.
In 2020 Google was accused of
mishandling the treatment of
minorities on the ethical AI team.
To start us off as these
events were happening,
what was going through your head?
What was your reaction?
>> No, one of the fortunate things
have felt as most companies
from day one Google has had
a strong employee voice.
And for me as a CEO running a large
company, always found it helpful.
Because you trust your employees
to get it right at scale.
So I viewed it as a strength of
the company, when employees speak up.
I think it's important for
us to take it seriously.
The walkout was a moment when the company
hadn't gotten something right and
that's what the walkout was about.
So internalizing it, acknowledging it,
owning up to it, committing and
making the company better is
how you approach those moments.
And even today, I think employee
input is something as a company,
we value deeply, and I would argue,
they push the company to be
better across all the things we do
It is complex, as I said earlier.
The context around some of these
decisions are always hard.
And at scale,
not everyone has the full context.
But for what it's worth,
I've personally always felt one
of the strengths of the company.
And when it comes to getting AI right or
doing things at scale, and
getting it right.
We do it in many countries
around the world.
And I still today take great comfort
in knowing that our employees deeply
are guardians of our values and
we'll do everything to get it right.
>> Yeah, and
I guess these past events help inform
the future decision making of Google.
How are you thinking about promoting
DE&I Diversity, Equity and
Inclusion at Google moving forward?
>> One of the most important moments
as a company we went through and
I think many companies around
the world was the racial equity moment
around the murder of George Floyd,
as a company for us.
It was a profound moment internally.
I've never seen anything affect
the company that much in the 16 years.
We publicly committed to, I consulted and
work with our black leadership
advisory group in the company.
And understanding most of the company,
he wanted to do the right thing,
tapping on the moment and
converting it into lasting commitment.
So we publicly committed
to a set of initiatives and
we're holding ourselves accountable.
We give transparency reports on
how we're making progress on that.
And be it committing to improving
our leadership representation
from underrepresented groups committing
to driving improvements in our products.
Last year in pixel in our camera
technology we launched real tone in
a more inclusive way to capture
pictures to cover all skin tones.
I mean, these are all examples
of how you can use technology to
make progress here scaling and
giving more people access to technology,
particularly in underrepresented groups.
These are all commitments we have made.
And that's one part of how we
work through moments like those.
>> Yeah, so it seems like you're taking
a technological approach as well as
an empathetic approach, listening to your
employees, hearing what they have to say.
What's top of mind for
employees right now is the future of work.
You recently released your future
of work plan for Google employees.
And I can imagine you're balancing a lot
of perspectives that are competing.
How did you integrate competing
preferences when crafting your future of
plan work?
For me, for what it's worth,
I am incredibly excited about this
next face of how the future of work.
And I think 20 years ago,
Google was kind of, it's now done so
much around the valley,
people take it for granted.
But Google did rethink
what workspaces could be.
They thought workspaces could be fun.
We had slides in our offices, we bridged
we changed workplaces pretty radically.
We gave people a lot of agency our
employees had a lot of agency.
It felt fun to be in the offices.
And we didn't think that was at
odds of being productive, right.
So the sense of creating community
fostering creativity in the workplace,
collaboration all makes
you a better company.
I view giving flexibility
to people the same way.
To be very clear I do think we strongly
believe in person connections.
But I think we can achieve that
in a more purposeful way and
give employees again more agency and
flexibility.
So I think hybrid work is great.
We're going to leverage
the scale of the company.
We have many locations around the world so
people can move to other places and work.
We are starting with
a three two hybrid option.
But we have encouraged employees to
apply to be fully remote as well.
And we've supported 85%
of those applications.
So I'm excited,
you earlier asked about diversity.
One of the best ways we can now approach
diversity is actually showing up in places
where diverse talent is.
But more importantly,
when we get that talent then being
in communities which have
the supporting structure for them.
And so we are now in Atlanta,
in Chicago, in DC, recruiting employees.
I think being able to support the
participation of women in the workforce.
I think the flexibility is
going to be huge asset.
So I'm excited by it and
I think I find when people come back.
And people are very excited to come
back to the office, by the way.
As they opened up,
we are easily at over 70% already back to
our pre pandemic,
presence in the offices and it's growing.
But giving people that choice.
It always bothered me that
the stress around commutes.
Or when people at parent-teacher
conferences or doctor appointments
balancing all that, there's a lot of
stress which people who are carrying.
So, I think it gives us
a chance to rethink.
Also say technology, since we build
products like Gmail, Docs and so on.
It gives us a chance to rethink products
too, and make it all work better.
So, I think it's one of the most
exciting things that's happening in
the workforce and I think you'll
see the benefits of it over time.
>> Yeah, absolutely.
It seems like you're
emphasizing intentionality and
flexibility when it comes to hybrid work.
And your plans really do set the stage for
other companies in Silicon Valley and
beyond.
So we're all looking to you and
your leadership for
guidance on things like this.
So you also recently just
got back from Warsaw,
you were helping out with
the Ukraine refugee crisis.
How do you, when is it appropriate for
corporations to step in on public
issues like Ukraine and Russia?
>> Well, first of all, for
us we are directly involved
because both we have employees
in Ukraine and Russia.
Our products work in these regions,
being an information company at moments
like this, it's really critical for
us to get these moments, right.
So we approach it a few ways.
Foremost, the safety of our employees
like every other organization,
making sure employees are safe.
The second very critical for us is
getting access to information, right?
Tackling misinformation, removing,
what we felt were propaganda information.
And raising what we do in search and
YouTube at moments like that is
raising higher quality information,
including providing information
within Russia at moments like this.
It's been a large part of the work we do,
launching important things like air
raid alerts on Google maps in Ukraine.
Being in Watsa one of the things
that struck me and it's true for
pretty much everyone there,
an average Google employee had two
to three refugee families with them.
These are mainly women and children.
People don't speak the same
language all the time,
people are using Google Translate
on their phones to communicate.
So we have to do a sprint to get
the language translation working right.
We opened up a portion of our space
to NGOs as well as entrepreneurs from
Ukraine and more importantly,
we committed to investing in Poland.
So we announced a $700 million investment,
both in office space and
to hire more people in Poland.
And we're going to commit
to investing in Central and
Eastern Europe at this pivotal time.
But I think it definitely the war shows
how much we have to continue fighting for
and so
it's an important moment to get right.
>> Yeah, it's incredible to see
corporations like Google committing time,
resources, financial investment,
and technology to causes like this.
And I'm personally in awe of how
many causes that you're invested in.
Apart from Ukraine, Russia,
you also have announced plans
recently in investment in Africa.
And things like job skills training for
low to middle income folks.
More broadly,
how do you choose which causes you
want to invest your time and effort into?
>> It's a great question.
With a company at scale, there's a lot of
things that come your way I think you have
to be disciplined about where you
think Google can make a difference.
And what is a unique perspective or value
proposition you can bring to the table.
And over time we have understood
there are things we can do well and
things other organization's
are better at doing.
An area, for example,
given our focus on information,
skilling has been a big focus for
us, digital skilling.
I think, there's no substitute for
college but
unfortunately not everyone has access
to it and can afford to go to college.
And so skilling people bringing them,
giving them access to digital
skills has been a big push.
In the US,
we launched a career certificate program.
It's a nine month program,
we've done it on four major areas.
And we back it up with working
with employers to recruit people.
And it's been extraordinarily successful,
75,000 people have gone through it.
And almost 50% of it is from
underrepresented groups.
And when I look at the demand there
is from people for these things and
so I think as a society we need to
figure out about how we can scale and
give access to digital
skilling to more people.
But that's an area where we feel
Google can strongly contribute.
And so we choose and
get involved in areas like that
sustainability is one of the ones.
So we choose where we
think we can add value.
>> Yeah, so it seems like you look at your
strengths, and then look at what impact
you can make based off of your
strengths and pursue those issues.
>> That's right.
>> Yeah, and you touched on this
briefly about sustainability.
A couple years ago,
you announced this lofty goal of being
carbon neutral at Google by 2030.
And you have to unify many business units
and product lines to achieve this goal.
How are you going about getting the whole
company to rally behind a goal of
sustainability?
>> One of the important things and
if I could clarify one thing,
because it's sadder than people,
we've been carbon neutral since 2007.
So Google has been carbon
neutral since 2007, and
one of the earliest companies to do so.
Sustainability has long
been an important goal.
What we have now committed is by 2030 to
be carbon free, so not using offsets,
but actually running our
operations 24/7 carbon free.
That is a hard challenge,
because today we can use offsets and
that involves investing in developing
new technologies beyond wind and
solar, be carbon capture, how do you store
energy and to do it around the world.
And so, but it excites us because
it's a lot of R&D again, and
you can apply technology.
And we bought some of the earliest
wind and solar contracts in 2010,
and costs have fallen by
85% in the last 10 years.
And so again,
looking at these new technologies,
we just have a whole data center
now up and running with geothermal.
And so, tapping into new technologies, and
we want to bootstrap it and
help drive the technology and
the cost curve over the next decade so
that we can reach there.
But it's a challenge,
it stresses us out, but
incredibly excited as technologists
the chance to make progress.
>> Yeah, and none of these big initiatives
were asked of you and asked of Google,
these are things that you as a company and
you as a leader have decided to take on.
The theme for our slate of speakers
this year is Beyond Expectations.
So we'd love to hear what
motivates you to go above and
beyond what is expected
of a business leader.
>> I would tie it back
to the first question,
at least in the context of the work I do.
I travel around the world, and I still
today, particularly when you go into
emerging markets,
it's a very different view from here.
You see how eager people are to
get access to technology because
they understand how it'll
make their lives better.
So you see it, you feel it,
when I go to Vietnam, or India,
or Africa, and
there's a lot more work to be done.
And just in India recently,
we are working on a cheaper,
high quality smartphone,
maybe around the $30 price point.
And last week we just announced in Africa,
our product development center in Nairobi,
hiring engineers, UX designers and so on.
When you see the appetite and
the desire for people to make their lives
better by gaining access to technology,
that's what compels me to go beyond.
And I think its very consistent with
what our company has set out to do.
>> Yeah, I can tell how much
intentionality you have behind all
the initiatives within Google and
externally.
So truly, thank you so much for
giving us a framework and
ideas behind how you make decisions,
that we can kind of take away from here.
With that, we do have student questions,
so we can turn it over.
Right there.
>> Hi Sundar.
My name is Melissa Jiang, and
I was a former Tapestry employee,
so great to meet you.
My question is, going back to the year or
forward to the year 2030,
in what capacity do you see Alphabet
partnering the most with governments?
And this can be from tech access,
to grids, to search, and
what will make you feel most
proud of getting right?
>> The second part is,
I do think sustainability is going to
be the defining issue for
us to get right in the next decade or so.
So we are definitely committing Alphabet
seriously, just to get to a carbon
free goal would involve billions of
dollars in incremental investment from us.
But we think it's the right thing to do,
it would be good for us as a business,
I think over time.
But I think that is something I
want us to be able to get right and
I think, definitely something we'd
be proud of if we can get there.
To your first question,
I presume you're asking,
by 2030, how do you see us engaging
with governments and so on?
Okay, I think tech, one of the bigger,
more profound changes underway is I think
technology is going to
be a regulated industry.
And, part of,
as a company working at scale,
is anticipating,
working constructively with regulators.
Because I think at the end of the day,
technology affects citizens and so
every country is going to be
thinking about this deeply.
And take Europe's GDPR as an example,
it's an important foundational
privacy legislation, right?
And I think we anticipated,
we invested up almost 18 months
of work to get ready for it.
And I think it's given certainty to both
European citizens, it gives businesses
certainty about how to operate, so
that's one example of legislation working.
And so we would expect to be
constructively working with governments
around the world.
Arjuna mentioned AI.
And I think that's going to be
important for us to get right.
And I think governments will end up
playing a key role in the timeframe.
>> Hi, Sundar, I'm Shinies,
thank you for being here.
Yesterday we had the privilege of
having Barack Obama on campus.
And he spoke about how changes
in the way we communicate and
consume information has a massive
impact on our democracy.
So while Google is not
a social media company,
I'm curious to know what you see
Google's role in that debate is.
>> I mean, first of all,
I think it was an important speech.
And I think that's something we think
about deeply, it's in our stated mission.
If you think about search, this is what we
are trying to do for every query, right?
We are trying to sort what is
higher quality information.
And so,
it cuts to the essence of what we do.
In YouTube,
we brought the same principles.
Such a complex topic, but
maybe I can answer it with an example.
It's actually easier to do this as
a company when society agrees on an area,
so when society converges and agree.
You can see that happening in the context
of the war, Russia, Ukraine, and
I think that's why you see a lot of
companies be able to get it right.
When society is very divided
about where to draw the lines,
it inherently gets harder.
But the way we approach is generally
on important areas, to use YouTube
as an example, we raise what we think
of as authoritative information.
That's journalistic content, or
in the case of, if it's health related,
maybe from universities or hospitals or
public health organizations.
So we use those tools just like
we have done search to try and
think hard about what are higher
quality sources of information.
And we view that as a goal, and that's
one way by which we tackle the problem.
But it's an important issue and I think
part of it is, if there are better rules,
including laws and legislation,
I think it'll actually make it easier.
But you'll find writing the law and
legislation is hard, because I think as
a society, we're still grappling with
what we think is the right answer for
many of these things.
Hi, Sundar.
I'm the at the business school.
>> [LAUGH]
>> And also from Madras, so
it's really nice to meet you.
I used to work for the Gates Foundation
thinking about bringing innovation to
emerging markets in undeserved people.
So everything you say resonates.
My question is a more personal one.
During the work you do, there are many
difficulties, difficult moments,
highs and lows.
Do you have any everyday habits or
personal mantras that keep you
going when things get tough?
>> It's a great question.
First of all, in my most decisions
it took me a while to realize when
decisions come to you,
the higher up you are in an organization,
the easy decisions don't come to you,
right?
[LAUGH] By definition when
something has come to you,
it's because others have spent time
on it and they can't resolve it.
So in some ways I realized that.
So two things, one is,
I think you making that decision is
the most important thing you can do.
You're breaking a tie and it unlocks
the organization to move forward.
And so, it's an important thing.
One of the mentors here, Bill Campbell,
taught that to me early.
Every week he would see me, he would ask
me, what ties did you break this week?
And so it's always struck with me.
So I view making these decisions as,
you're really helping the company,
and so that makes it a bit more fun.
The second is, with time you realize most
of those decisions are inconsequential.
It might appear very tough at the time.
It may feel like a lot rides on it,
prelook later and
you realize it wasn't that consequential.
There are few consequential decisions,
and judgment is a big part of leadership,
and you don't always get it right and
you have to learn from it.
But I think most decisions
aren't that consequential.
And so thinking through both,
it helps me think about it as it's just
another normal day in the office,
and so you keep going through it.
>> So I think we have time for
one more question right back there.
>> Hi, Sundar.
My name is Nick Pershore.
I'm from Syria.
And in Syria,
20 million people don't have access
to all of the products
that Google produces.
That's because of regulations that
are put in place by countries like
the United States and
certain countries of the European Union.
So on top of being under a dictatorship,
20 million Syrians don't have access to
the financial world, don't have
access to basic technology products.
And the gap between the developed and
developing world is
really just increasing.
You're one of the most
important leaders in the world.
What are you doing to advocate
on behalf of these people and
give truly universal access
to technology products?
Thank you.
>> That's a great question.
As a company, our mission is to provide
universal access to information,
and anytime we are not able to do that for
a set of reasons.
I mean, we struggle with it,
we feel compelled to try to find a way.
We do have to comply
with laws as a company.
And in areas like Syria,
the ways we have contributed,
a, we've been involved in
the refugee workaround,
Syrian refugees for a long time.
We build access to open source
technologies in many of these cases and
support things.
Android is open source, things do
make their way into these countries.
So we work at the open source level in
areas where we are not fully able to
directly work.
But I think it's an important question.
I don't have all the answers here.
But thanks for asking it, and
I'll think about it more.
>> Awesome, so we typically conclude our
conversations with a lightning round.
I will start a sentence and
you will finish it.
So it's a fill in the blank.
>> [LAUGH]
>> So first of all,
something that inspires me is?
>> Watching the next generation blossom.
And I think society always
worries that the next generation
isn't as good as they are,
that is not true.
And the next generation ends up
making the world even better.
So that inspires me.
>> I am the most proud of?
>> Trying my best to do the right
thing by the people I'm involved with,
both obviously, personally and
professionally, people I work with.
>> During my time at Stanford, I loved?
>> I used to love just
being out in the court, and
sitting and grabbing lunch with friends.
Driving today reminded me of that,
for sure.
>> I am the happiest when?
>> Many things, but
being around people, building products,
and solving problems makes me very happy.
>> And finally, the best piece of
leadership advice I've received is?
>> Be authentic to yourself and
be the best leader you can be.
I think there's no one right template, and
don't try to be in someone else's mold.
>> That's wonderful.
Sundar, thank you so much.
It's been such a pleasure.
>> [APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC]